We could just be puh-dump- oh my god.
We could just be dumping water, somewhere not knowing where it goes.
Today we are getting visited by Sawyer Hartman.
He's another YouTuber who's actually more of a filmmaker, director personality
which is really cool. There's a not a whole lot of those on YouTube.
I'm really looking forward to getting to hang out with him a little bit, getting to meet him
now I think he's coming over because he saw the VR backpack video that we made
And he's really excited to try it out. And I'm kind of worried
because. I don't really have it one hundred percent up and running yet.
*laughs*
I just walked into the studio and it was just pouring now it's starting to dribble.
What the frack?
This one was doing it yesterday.
Here's the question. How many AC units do you have to install, where two-
*Off-camera barking* I know, Bandit. I know.
Where two out of the three, leak water. When you get done with them.
That means he's got a 67% failure rate on installation.
How many times have you done this?
Uh Jake. We have an issue.
There's a pipe in the tool room that's leaking water all over the shelves.
In our tool room?
Yes. :/
So now there's a puddle in the tool room.
Whaaat?
Drip. Like drip drip drip drip drip drip drip.
Ahhh, fuck.
Wren: That's what I heard I was walking by and that's what I heard.
Jake: It'll drip and then it'll stop.
And then it'll start again...
So, let's go first to the roof to cut off the source of the problem.
An AC unit leaks water, because it's an inverter.
And all the cool air turns to water and yeah it has to get rid of it.
So usually there's an exit pipe that you either filter into a garden or into the sewer, whatever.
Does that look like it might be going somewhere?
Where do you think that's going?
Into our tool room! >:/
That's
This is. Yeah this has to be it.
These air conditioning units are supposed to last for years.
The solution being, let's run piping, without securing it across the roof, to a place we don't know where it goes
Without actually clamping it down
Cmike: Hey man he's only been doing it for 30 years.
That's the thing, dude.
I don't- That's what I don't get.
My dad was a union carpenter for like 25 years and it's this kind of shit that when he came home,
when I was a child and he was upset
and I didn't understand why
It's because of this kind of shit.
And now I get it.
So, Sam's still in Iceland, and Jake and I have a whole bunch of work we gotta do
To try and get these bigger projects off the ground.
So we need some help to pull off the next video.
Now Gabe has a bit of an animation background.
And Wren obviously has a great visual background
And Peter...
No one knows what his background is actually like.
But the thing is we asked them to get together and design the stop motion action scene
for the next video.
Curious to see what they come up with. I'm sure it'll be a mish-mash of a bunch of different cool ideas.
Okay so. From the ground I can see both walls and where the cross beam meets the wall.
I wanna find like the cross between enough resolution but also enough coverage.
So we wanna shoot the whole entire thing in here and we wanna do it with no visual effects.
Or at least no visible VFX.
You had a good idea to actually attach some sort of dolly system to the rafter up there
So we can move the camera. But, it would be way easier if we didn't have to move the camera at all.
And just shoot wide enough to cover everything.
Good to see you. How are you doing?
But yeah like I mostly make narratives. I made a feature film last year.
But 88 days ago now, I decided to make a film every single day for 391 days.
391?
Yeah. Every day until my 27th brithday.
Oh, okay.
So now that's kind of like, taken over my life.
What's your schedule like when you have to put a video out everyday?
Depends what I'm doing. I always try to structure them like three act stories.
Like get a good chunk of it in the morning
Find the meat in the story in the afternoon
And get the wrap up at night.
So I really enjoy showing people VR for the first time.
I've gotten to do it quite a bit now which is great.
And pretty much always people's minds are blown.
And it doesn't matter if you are my mom who has never touched video games before in her life.
Or if you are one of my friends who plays video games all the time.
It all has the same reaction.
Watching people yell and scream and laugh and take off their headset
And like realize they're still in the real world and like come to terms with whether or not they know
If they're actually in the real world... That's the best part.
Holy crap.
It's so weird to like "step out of it?"... yeah
Yeah back to reality? "yeah."
Dude, that was so amazingly cool.
What's happening?
The air conditioning guys messed up again
They came to me of course, to fix it, clean it, whatever needs to be done.
My concern is that the water's gotten into the walls
So I'd be interested to see what Gabe, comes back with.
If he doesn't dry it all out. Then we're gonna have mold get in there and that's not a good thing.
We pretty much caught it, before it caused any real damage.
If Wren hadn't just walked by and heard the water falling, then this place would've been flooded.
Since he caught it I think just when it started, that saved me from a lot of work.
What I don't understand is why is he using copper pipe of all metals?
Cmike: What's the problem with copper?
Copper's expensive.
We could just be dumping water, somewhere, not knowing where it goes.
How is this okay? Now what do we do with these?
And look it how much unnecessary extra piping he used.
Did he charge us for all that piping?
You know he did, dude.
Yeah it's just zip-tied like that. That's his "five year solution".
Because there's no more money in the budget, then why didn't he just quote me higher?
Like I want it done right. I don't want i done, super cheap.
So I mean the gist of it is like alright this guy is walking his dog
and some soldier comes out of nowhere.
And then a fight begins. We choreograph that how we want
but in order to realistically, figure out what we're gonna be doing we have to know our bounds.
and our bounds is where the field of view of the camera ends.
and we now know that with this set up, I think we can get the entire room.
So I think now that we have a pretty good idea of how we're gonna be filming this stuff
we should figure out what we're gonna be filming.
So Gabe-
Peter: I think we should start story boarding :|
Took the words right out my mouth.
We should start story boarding.
Subscribe for more vlogs and behind the scenes awesomeness!